so today I'll be talking about how we
instrumented some of our integration
tests at SLAC to enable us to keep tabs
on potential performance regressions on
our back-end piece of the application
and it's story about developing internal
tools that are useful to developers that
developers actually enjoy to use and
help us not step on our toes when we're
rapidly shipping code out to production
so a little bit about me I'd like to
claim that this is the moment when I
started programming but it is not that's
my dad's old machine I think it was
running ms-dos 5 at the time but I
really only started programming
completely by accident in the second
half of my first year of university
since then I've done a short stint as a
front-end engineer at a fashion startup
in New York and then eventually I made
my way over to San Francisco where I've
worked in a bunch of different roles
specifically on the backend side at
flack for three years now
I don't tweet very much but you are more
than welcome to follow me on Twitter and
or tweet about this talk while I'm
giving it there's any slides that you
particularly like take pictures of them
I will definitely go through afterwards
and look at everything so that is
something that I will actually do into
it so in my current role at slack I
spend a lot of my time making developers
lives simpler more pleasant and more
productive and that might sound a little
bit cheesy but I did pull it from
official slack branding so you know that
it's legit but in all seriousness a
little bit more concretely our team
deals with a lot of different things and
so one of the things that we work on is
upgrades to our language stack our
back-end is written entirely in hackling
and run on top of the hip hop vm so
these are both technologies that are
open sourced out of Facebook they made
the decision to hard fork off of PHP a
little bit over a year ago and since
then they've very aggressively shipped
new changes to the language and they're
iterating and shipping a new minor
version almost every week now so that
keeps us very busy we also have
stewardship of our core libraries so
these are library
that pretty much every back an engineer
at slack uses at some point when they're
developing a new feature this includes
logging or metrics gathering libraries
sometimes our database access libraries
we also own all of our linking tools and
our unit and integration testing
frameworks and finally and this is the
piece that I really want to cover today
and sort of in conjunction with the
previous point we have a tool that
performs monitoring of potential
performance reactions before they go out
to production so in order to kind of set
the picture for this last piece I want
to rewind our clocks to the summer of
2017
and at the time we were working in an
increasingly growing code base where it
was becoming really really difficult to
keep everything in our head and we were
trying to keep everything in her heads
while we were shipping new features and
at the time we had this nearly entirely
flat directory structure so most of our
back-end code was in files called Lib
thing under the include subdirectory and
so there was no real reasoning about
where certain ownership of files began
and certain ownership ended it was
really tough to reason about where
anything was
you kind of guessed crept around a lot
so as you can imagine building a feature
was really quite straightforward really
easy generally involved just a few
simple steps first you identify any of
the API is involved or if you needed to
write a new API you'd find all the
relevant code to modify you'd add a few
if statements you know to handle the
thing that you were there to handle
you'd grep around for similar code
because certainly there was someplace
else this was this was being handled
probably exactly the same way and you'd
add a few more if statements to cover
that piece of the code and then you
typic great good job and it wasn't
incredibly sustainable as you can
probably see given that we were also on
top of all this onboarding a ton of new
engineers at this crazy breakneck pace
so it was a little bit like trying to
launch a fast food restaurant with like
a ten page menu out of a tiny
York apartment kitchen and then trying
to increase the throughput by just
throwing more chefs at the problem
instead of just redesigning the kitchen
and I don't know how many of you have
played overcooked my husband and I
played through this game in just a
couple days mostly by himself with me
just falling over the edges with fully
cooked meals if you have been played
over cooked I highly recommend you do
it's a really great way to test your
relationship without having to go to
Ikea and if you think that's it there's
more to throw into this problem so on
top of all these growing pains right
we're deploying code to production and
every time we're deploying code to
production were deploying it from zero
to a hundred percent of our servers in
under a minute we had very few gates and
guardrails letting us know what we were
actually shipping to production and I
know there's some people in the room who
actually know this number but how many
times do you think we were shipping to
production in an average San Francisco
workday any guesses who said a hundred a
hundred and sure it dips around like
lunch time when everyone was like out
getting food but then it picked right
back up so we had very very little
visibility into how just a single line
change could impact the performance of
our application and sure it was great
cuz we were shipping 0 to 100 incredibly
fast so you know if bad things happen in
production just revert and then that's
another deploy out of 100 who cares
turns out large enterprise customers
care a lot surprisingly at this time I
was working on a team that was tasked
with improving flex back in performance
specifically for those largest customers
and because a lot of our code was really
difficult to reason about it wasn't
uncommon for things to get shipped you
know every couple of one of those
hundred instances and then we had to go
and fix it and it was completely
completely to easy to completely
innocently author code which would run
out of memory on these largest teams or
just introduced a new Oh N
linear database dependency whatever and
it's not because we didn't test our
changes we tested a lot of our changes
manually but we'd test them out on these
tiny test teams where you'd have ten
users and like a dozen channels this is
not representative of our most common
slack user and definitely not
representative of the large enterprise
customers so with many of these changes
going out on a really regular basis it
felt like our team was just like
treading water and fire fighting all the
time and we had these visions for how
the performance as the application could
be so much better if we just had time to
stop treading water and start swimming
laps right so in an effort to give
ourselves a little bit more of that
bandwidth we thought okay we need to
build something which will help us
identify all these potential performance
regressions before anyone's able to
merge that code so we decided to protect
ourselves from ourselves and this is the
thing that a lot of programmers do and
every programmer every good programmer
knows that a good tool needs a good name
and at the time we were naming a bunch
of our tools using some combination of
slack and the purpose of the tool right
so our PHP turned hackling linter the
slack PHP linter was obviously called
splinter like Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles clearly we were building a slack
performance tool so the only appropriate
name for this tool would obviously be
slur from now on I will refer to this
tool as slur and we made a logo for it
because a good logo means success so we
were equipped with a name and a simple
goal protect our api's and these are the
lifeblood of the application so if our
application is unable to respond to
client requests in a timely manner slack
enters a degraded State and our
customers are definitely not happy so it
seemed like a really good place to start
we dug through our usage patterns to
identify set of api's which are hit most
often on a regular workday and
not a perfect metric but it does give us
a good sense of those where customers
are most likely to notice at performance
regressions so it seemed like a good
place to start
we somewhat arbitrarily chose the top 15
partly because once we hit the we pulled
the top 50 and once it reached the 16th
the usage drop-off was pretty big
sometimes you make these sorts of
arbitrary decisions and that's okay
you're really kind of iterating on
building a tool and you'll see what
works so this is a screenshot of the top
15 api's when we first launched the tool
in October two years ago and we built
this little bot that query runs some
queries and reports which api's are most
called over the last 24 hours
and it's still alert today in alerts
slurve every Monday at 3 p.m. I can't
reveal the exact numbers for like
business reasons but I can give you a
sense of the scale of some of these
numbers so the first one is tens of
millions of times over 24-hour period
and the 15th is millions of times over a
24-hour period
the only blurred out api's are the
private EP is that we don't publicly
show to third-party developers but the
other ones you might be familiar with
and you might even see some of the
blurred ones if you open up your network
tab next time you use things like it so
these ApS were used across most if not
all of our clients and many by
third-party developers and most deal
dealt with either establishing a
connection to slack or reading content
across different channels and these
things are absolutely critical to using
slack in general so we wanted to make
sure that they were as fast and reliable
as possible thankfully our hypothesis
hay worked out and this is a screenshot
from a couple weeks ago and just to give
you a sense of the different lists of
the ones you can't actually see but the
top API in this case from a couple weeks
ago was called twice the number of times
as the top API two years ago and then
the bottom one is I believe TEDx and so
it's a much tighter cluster but mainly
this is just a satisfied
you'll probably notice that my slack is
in French
I used slack in French I grew up
speaking French and when we launched
slack internationally they went
internally and said hey if you speak
another language please switch slack to
the other language if it's one of the
languages we're translating slack - I
never switched it back because I think
it's a great thing to be dogfooding your
own product and so every so often I'll
pop into a channel and I'd be like this
a weed or weird bug I'm experiencing
here and there like was this reported by
French in France customer and I'm like
no I work here I'm like three desks away
from you okay I digress so we had this
information and what were we going to
build we decided to build the most low
effort MVP we could possibly conceive of
given everything that we had available
to us at the time so thankfully we had a
lot of those tools that were available
to us and we'll just take a look at a
few of those so we had continuous
integration great check awesome every
time that a commit was pushed to our
github Enterprise instance it would kick
off this whole flow which read through a
list of tests and ran all of those tests
we also had access to a number of QA
environments which we could deploy
individual branches to for testing and
these curie environments read from our
development databases so every test team
that we'd spun up to manually test some
things while we pushed our code to dev
branches we could also reuse those teams
in QA and finally well this isn't
technically infrastructure we had really
verbose debug logs available to us and
this is a little bit what that looks
like so if you hit an API in slack and
you're on a dev or a QA instance and you
have the right permissions you can pass
them an extra pram debug equals one and
it'll tell you information about
everything that the API called out to to
satisfy the request and so as we can see
here it returned some information about
the total time spent connecting to the
database the number of connections that
it made the total time query in the
database the number of queries that it
ran etc and in this output we cared
about two specific metrics so we cared
about the number of database queries and
we cared about the number of memcache
queries because we use memcache
as a distributed caching solution and
you might be thinking that relying on
these two pieces of information is a
little bit simplistic or naive but you
know you're thinking performance is not
always tied to data fetching what is
this it's tied to timing and all sorts
of fancy performance things but it turns
out at the time that most of our sears
performance problems were nearly always
related to database operations of some
kind or around data fetching of some
kind so for instance we discovered that
at one point for every single unread
message you had in a thread that you
were subscribed to if you went to read
those messages from your threads all of
you if you're familiar with that for
every single one of those messages
before it loaded it it would check that
you were in the channel you're still in
the channel like it's ten messages from
the same thread let me tell you you've
probably still in that channel so we
found all these sorts of problems and we
really wanted to make sure that we were
not making these sorts of silly mistakes
but I do want to take a second to
acknowledge all the other types of data
that was available to us in the debug
logs that we could have used to spot
regressions specifically with regards to
monitoring or data usage so we could
have looked at timings data but that
would have been actually really
unreliable and unrepresentative of
application behavior because our test
infrastructure really wasn't that
reliable at the time so our dev
databases depending on the time of day
were under various amounts of load and
so if it was really busy handling some
sort of requests from some automated
testing suite elsewhere the timings data
would be completely out of whack and our
QA memcache tier had also varying
availability throughout the day so if we
look at the timings well then we weren't
really comparing apples to apples and
because this was a test that we
deliberately wanted to introduce as a
gate to merging code it needed to be
reliable it needed to be something that
people could trust and read the results
and be like oh I did actually do
something and not just say slurps blinky
again otherwise you know if we'd have a
complete developer mutiny on our hands
and I personally did not want a
developer mutiny on my hands
so how did this thing work so first we
would deploy a branch to a QA
environment so based off of the commit
hugs
we'd map grab your latest commit push
that out to a development environment QA
environment saw the sari rather and then
we would get all of the API is that we
wanted to test from the slurp service
that was the 15 api's that i mentioned
earlier and then we do this sort of
dance so for each of those api's we'd
run the api against your code running on
a QA environment that we identified then
we'd run the same exact api against
master QA environment which was updated
every 15 to 20 minutes we'd record both
of those runs both of the debug outputs
from those API requests we'd record that
with our service and then we'd compare
the results and we generated a report
and unfortunately the report wasn't
super informative because we were only
looking at query counts so we only
reported query campus and it was up to
the code author to figure out where they
might have introduced new dependencies
and so given how much code there is to
handle D&D team info I'm not sure how
long it might have taken this person to
figure out exactly where they might have
introduced two new database queries if
the change is really small sometimes
it's really obvious if the change is a
little bit bigger than good luck to you
but you know it was the best we could do
at the time and it was enough to really
keep the bugs or rather the performance
issues at bay another thing to note on
this slide
is the green button so we made sure that
there was some sort of middle ground
if slurve observed a regression and
blocked your PR you could acknowledge
the failure and just rerun the test
suite and merge your change it would
pass it would be fine you could go if
you felt confident that either the
results were really wrong and you let us
know in Channel or you did actually
fully intend to add this new database
dependency then hey we're not going to
tell you what to do just like go and do
the thing like the spine so
had this acknowledged flow which was
really great and it also actually
enabled us to have less friction in
setting it as a blocking test to merging
code to production and I went live about
mid October of 2017 and here's a more
zoomed in view of what that looked like
and will see the modern version of the
tool later so overall we definitely
considered the tool success but there
were some not-so-great bits so we did
actually catch performance regressions
early on slur flirted on various changes
that would have considerably slowed a
subset of production api's and in some
cases actually probably brought down the
entire application so that was fantastic
Maggie's great she like pops into
channel almost weekly just tell us that
sort of caught something of some kind so
really keeps us going but we thought
we'd avoided most of the unreliability
problems around the QA environments
because we weren't looking at timings
and that sort of thing but because our
repo is a lot the time was just so large
it wasn't uncommon for the deployment
process of taking your branch shipping
it to a QA environment and then
unpacking it and doing everything that
you needed to do to get it up and
running and able to accept API requests
again that took sometimes fifteen
minutes to run and so that wasn't great
and then came the extra not so great and
you know it's good when you're CTO calls
out your tool in the very public Channel
so while we could work to stabilize a
bunch of our testing infrastructure and
decrease all the set-up time that was
all doable things there were some pretty
serious limitations to how slurve worked
under the hood and it became pretty
clear about a year after we launched the
testing suite and there was a code
change that was made which introduced a
new database read on every single slack
comm wedge web page view and that just
kind of made it out to production and it
completely brought the application down
and
then we kind of sat there and we're like
oh no why didn't slurve catch this and
that's because the tool issued API
requests to a QA environment it
completely treated it as a black box and
had no visibility into what the
application was actually doing beyond
the debug output it was receiving and
that was only for API as it wasn't for
web pages and so we were unable to test
the performance of our long-running
processes so like jobs on our job queues
or indexing processes and we were
entirely unable to test web pages backed
by a hag hack line code and that was a
serious problem so we hatched a new plan
and we went about doing that in a way
that probably sounds too very familiar
we built a low effort and VP given
existing infrastructure so we sat down
and we took another look at what we had
and that's when we kind of had this aha
moment
why not benchmark our integration tests
which sounds weird when you phrase it
this way but you have to understand what
makes them really powerful as a tool and
here are some of those things so it's
really easy to build up and teardown
environments unique to each test and
I'll show an example a little bit more
in depth of all of these next you can
also track database and memcache usage
through all of our mocking libraries
that we've set up there are no external
dependencies whatsoever so no deployment
to a QA environment and there's already
a wide range of existing tests that test
production behavior that's really
critical to the application so this is
what a test setup looks like in some of
our integration tests in our actual code
and so it creates a test team and it
creates a test user and then you just
have your test case our ability to tear
down to set these up and tear them down
and build different types of teams
different types of channels different
types of users to exercise exactly the
right kind of behavior that we want is
it's really expressive and the set up is
pretty speedy and really well isolated
between our different test cases so this
is something that we can leverage in
order to set up all the specific
benchmarking scenarios that we want a
benchmark and it's much improved over
relying on these generalize to
development test teams that we'd set up
development databases which grow stale
over time and sometimes because you're
testing on these dev test teams that
you've set up you purposefully break
them and that's not something that we
would ever want in the blocking test the
second piece is tracking database and
memcache usage through mocking libraries
so we have these mocking libraries that
kind of kick in at the network boundary
of our application when we're running
all these integration tests and these
libraries vary wildly in complexity so
some attempt to mimic the behavior of
the external system with a really high
degree degree of fidelity and others
accept input and just kind of give you
hard coded output back but one of our
more sophisticated libraries is sequel
fake so it provides a near-complete
in-memory simulation of my sequel it was
recently open sourced by one of my
teammates and you can check it out on
github really great tool it was and on
the other hand our memcache mock which
you can see us calling out to here is
just a key value store in memory like
that's what memcache is it's just not
distributed so because these mocks are
developed by us internally they give us
an incredible amount of flexibility and
we can extend them to gather more
metrics and exactly the format that we
want slave to consume and then another
great piece is we had no external
dependencies so we did not rely on
development databases or QA memcache
it's incredibly convenient to be able to
run the full suite of tests from your
repo directly rather than deploying it
to this environment and if you have a
local check out of the repo at that
point you can actually run slor' locally
on your machine and we had a wide range
of existing tests so given we already
had a bunch of these
we could start benchmarking tests
basically immediately once we made these
changes to serve and not all of our
tests might be good candidates for
benchmarking so this is definitely one
that is not because we stub out actual
behavior that is internal to the API but
there are a bunch of tests that don't
step out this behavior and this is an
example of one of those where all it
does is it calls to the
API given some test arguments and
expects the response this is a great
candidate for benchmarking we're we're
exercising all the critical behavior and
all of its side effects so we introduced
a simple function to begin benchmarking
all of these tests and this is the
actual implementation of slurve
benchmark basically what it does is it
takes an anonymous function and a set of
options we're not gonna worry about the
set of options today but it creates a
new benchmark so that's that first line
BM and it takes next a snapshot of all
of our testing mocks before executing
the code so that's BM pre run then it
executes the code and saves the output
of that code to a temporary variable so
that's output running the anonymous
function then it'll take another
snapshot after it's run the code that it
needed to execute finally it'll compute
the difference between the pre run and
the post run that's basically just a
diff of queries and query counts and
then it outputs the result of the
anonymous function and this is what it
might look like embedded within an
actual integration test so we're just
running the integration test for files
dot list with some test arguments we
happen to be benchmarking it but really
it doesn't matter within the entire
scope of the test so how does this all
work together first we check out the
code at your latest commit we enable
slurps don't worry about it being bash
wizard here I've had to look this up as
I was writing this and every time I've
had to modify it I've also had to google
it but that's okay Google is great
basically all this does is it finds all
the references to all the test files
that have slurve benchmark and then for
each of those it'll run all of those
test files and in parallel because it
saves us a lot of time each individual
test file is a test file that can be run
on its own using this test wrap unit
script and then it will repeat those
steps but for the master branch and then
finally we run the evaluation script so
as we are evaluating each of these
benchmarks were outputting JSON files to
disk on the C
a box that's running all of this and so
we take all those output files we match
them up by ID from your branch running
this specific benchmark and master
running at a specific benchmark we'll do
the comparison there and in these
comparisons were actually able to
collect much richer information about
what operations were going on the under
the hood we saved all this stuff into
those JSON files and it gives us much
much more informative results in the UI
afterwards and so once we've collected
all that information we created this
evaluation we report the results and so
this is what the new version of sloth
looks like we have a whole bunch of new
categories so we not only look at
regressions we looked at different tests
that were acknowledged so if you did in
intend to actually make that change and
you acknowledged it that we keep track
of that any improvements which are great
if you removed any tests so if you
removed a benchmark just because it
wasn't doing what you wanted it to do
that's fine but we also require you
acknowledge that if you added benchmarks
great we love you know status something
went wrong with the evaluation and no
change everything is actually totally
the same between your branch and master
good job we also now are able to show
you the full queries that we think might
have been added the api's that we think
might have been impacted and a complete
call stack where we think that new query
is happening which is so much better
from a developer perspective when you're
being told slope is failing oh no you
can actually find where it thinks these
new queries are happening and if you do
actually ship an improvement we give you
confetti so let's cover the good bad and
be not ugly of this new setup so we were
able to catch performance regressions
with this new setup as well it's much
much faster and it's now easier than
ever to add these benchmarks we're not
relying on these 15 top called api's
anymore the alert still goes off because
it's interesting to see these usage
patterns but now people can just
benchmark anything that they think is
relevant and now we're benchmarking
nearly 800 different code paths
in comparison to the 15 prior so it's a
much safer world to be in unfortunately
with any testing suite the more you add
tests this you slow the whole thing down
so while slurp is not the longest
running test that is blocking merges to
production currently it's getting up
there so that'll be definitely something
that we have to address in the future
and it's so the ugly I'll talk about the
amazing so because our mocks make slurve
completely extensible we're looking to
introduce different metrics around
memory usage where we can pre run record
the amount of memory that's used post
run record the amount of memory that's
used easily subtract the amount of
memory that we're using for our
in-memory mocks and report that finding
we can also look at the number of rows
returned because sequel faked is
basically an in-memory sequel
implementation we can actually trust
those numbers and timings data so
because we have no network dependencies
in our integration tests the timing's
data is actually somewhat reliable it
might not look like production but
running the same exact tests in the same
exact way between your branch and master
should return reliable results so some
takeaways if there's anything you should
take away from our experience Whistler
apart from great names and logos make
things great you should learn to build
from what you have take inventory of the
tools you have available to you and you
might be surprised to see the different
creative ways that you can combine them
you might not get an optimal solution
but you might be able to get a
surprisingly effective approximation and
if it is an approximation that's when
you have to gate responsibly and what I
mean by this is that if you're planning
to introduce a new test that's able to
block merges you have to think really
carefully about what you want that
interaction to look like for developers
on the other side so we were able to
make slur for blocking test because we
had a way for developers to acknowledge
all these failures and move on we
trusted them to make the right call and
that's really paid off for us and I just
want to thank all these wonderful people
who were tons left with me there
here but they might watch this on
YouTube at some point and they were
great
I also brought slurve stickers with me
and they're at the slacked table outside
sure it's the old logo who cares it's
got a Smurfs hat on it it's cute it's an
internal tool branding whatever thank
you
[Applause]